hello and welcome to this video playing
making no sense yeah I should get some
wins and my rating is down to something
which is really too low but not having a
good good session here giving away too
many useless games useless games it's
wrong I mean giving giving things away
for free is what I'm trying to say so
what flying is he playing yeah this one
okay oh wow this is not good playing
something like that against me here yeah
this is a funky sideline which I have no
idea about I only know that is very
tricky du'a for non è for player do
those lines are them the other the
toughest want to meet ya where if you
know it and you probably have something
something which is okay at least and if
you have no idea like i have it then it
can prove extremely tricky to play okay
but okay no this one what about this the
Queen takes and a six or something well
okay I mean at least this is a position
where I can never be worse maybe I can
be worse f5 is an interesting movie 596
you
the somewhat interesting movie 5 but
yeah this is I've seen things like that
where the e5 pawn all the sudden gets to
be a problem may be in place g5 here
they're probably not chief I offered no
g6 rookie one when he has to do
something he cannot allow f4 I mean if I
getting f4 he's basically busted more or
less busted I mean maybe can go g5 then
but I think he has to attack me five now
96 or maybe this g5 move or f4f what
could also be something yeah so this was
the normal the normal moves let's say
not happy about who came one but i
probably have to play that
and probably go a 60 all right maybe a
six then be 56 h 5 night-night f-4s is
probably wrong like after we gauge to
and threatening g3 then I Scott t5 as a
square okay and the other option is rook
age form but probably not good
hmm yeah this is kind of okay for black
this is kind of okay
still going for age 42 it still looks
okay I mean I don't think I'm were
seeing the deponent still looks like a
problem maybe I should have actually
played see form instead I should have
plates you for maybe it's God Bishop
before now now anyway it's difficult for
him to play the deep one some but what
do i have to i play this really not sure
this look has to go to d2 and i would
like to get rid of this the bishop i'm
unsure if i should go see for him okay
this decision is basically now he now
made this decision for me couldn't place
your form first may I can go see three
here yes I should I would like to get
rid of get rid of both pieces this would
be good Bishop g2 and then some nights
e2 e3 this this would be good but
let's cover this first
I wonder if he has some kind of crazy
thing on Syria they don't think so right
no light takes III here to irritate me
it could could be a bit irritating but
not now I can go King be 20 came and
came to King me too I'm covering the
second-ranked so this is not really a
problem yeah no I'm threatening night f5
which he does not really react to should
work well in 96 I have
right doesn't have a square way to text
one of my books so I should win some
material here yeah I'm winning the
exchange look see one yes probably oh
and assess this is a bit annoying really
hmm can I do yeah I will still take this
and now let's no let's see here rook c8
rook e8 doesn't do much I will never
should go by five hi morning you know
it's probably not not a bad idea chicky
six is also hanging so let's get the
beep on going
should be it should be difficult for him
to really catch it mmm he's got a check
here would be five God would be too I
can I have to do this one would be cool
down
should work check black forfeits on time
yeah I was there was a tough game this
is a tricky line really tricky line pins
bishops in fact I've seen this analyzed
somewhere and what I remember is that it
it leads to quite murky positions well I
don't know Bishop f4 my was my move and
at least the engine does not immediately
disapprove of it so what capsules it
felt quite quite logical and yeah he s s
f5 stuff so f5 hmm yeah this is a good
idea I've seen this but I wasn't quite
available during the game that a five
would be coming but it's very it's a
very logical move if he gets to trade
ever against youporn let's say I I
didn't I develop like the engine wants
to do what he might get his two pawns in
the center that depth get moving like
here yes the engines line okay seven Wow
yeah well if he gets in like d5 be 5 and
so on this is not so bad i mean i don't
think that white should be worse in this
position as confirmed by the computer
would not i don't like it much this is a
very m committal move I was even
thinking that this could be an option
but age 4 is good he said good game yeah
I think so it was a it was an
interesting game for sure yeah maybe I
was thinking he maybe could take and go
here but the computer finds this a6f for
it's a bitter
yeah he says I couldn't drove the line
but I don't think wide usually play c5 I
don't know why yeah probably because the
e porn is somewhat somewhat a
reliability of it I really wasn't sure I
think this is failed reasonably okay
here rookie one given by the computer
that's it it's probably a goodness
looking at this pawn and then we'll get
fun yeah the thing is in this kind of
situation you probably cannot take as
the the night now is trapped I mean this
feels very very difficult for black now
k what I did is probably not not the
best but I'm still kind of holding a
small edge I wasn't sure if c4 is
correct him I mean at the end up
probably probably I should do it I
wasn't sure because and maybe here I
should actually play because i don't
have f4 played so I was kind of scared
he gets a good square here but I can
always push him push him back and this
looks a little bit strange share but he
cannot attack the pawn so the engines
available slight edge might be correct
the Seaforth also limits the night so
compared to what we got with the team
having be five and maybe c4 was
preferable I had to slow plan of just
trading trading the the minor pieces
like it happened and and like here here
and now my next step would have been
nights e2 e3 to trade this and at the
end get to the d7 porn that was my
long-term plan and it doesn't feel like
it's a bad plan as you see the entrance
line is kind of it's kind of the same
idea but yeah if he played this one
after which I can take and yeah I'm just
winning stuff not sure if I plated the
best technically of it
it probably was sufficient v6p to look
here yeah I didn't didn't blunder
anything I can always you are there at
the edge of the board and opponents got
some night and Roku always scared of the
Reagan made ok guys thanks for watching